So defining the postcondition for
permutation is a little tricky.
Here's one answer that is worth
studying to ensure yourself that you
truly understand how a formal
specification might look.
We will break down the specification
of permutation into several different
special cases.
Okay?
And this is a typical approach for
tricky specifications or even for tricky
programs, is to break them down into
special cases and handle each one
of those special cases by itself.
Okay, the first case to look at
is when both vectors are empty.
We already know that the lengths are the
same, so if we say, we can check whether
they're empty by just checking whether
the length of the vector x equals zero.
And, in that case,
we already talked about this,
we will say that they have the same,
well no we didn't talk about it.
We talked about it with order.
So, if we have an empty vector and
we know that the lengths are the same,
that's saying we're going to
have an empty vector as output,
is that output vector
a permutation on the input vector?
It is.
Okay.
So, special case number one,
the length of the input vector is zero.
We will say, in fact, that the output
is a permutation of the input.